alors là mais cette ville justement
gérard hernandez est remonté remonté à
bloc par les séductions ces moments les
coulisses la wii tous les deux très bien
vous êtes très séduisant oui merci
comment comment on peut séduire
justement j'ai demandé est ce qu'il faut
faire qu'il faut c'est très simple oui
c'est il faut rien faire c'est ça se
fait tout seul mais très bien c'est pas
fatiguant ya plus dur car écoutez je
vous allez enfin donc salle
mais jean se frustre régate pourquoi
parce que je suis très distant pêche pas
distrait je suis toujours branché autre
chose s'était fait que je marche je peux
tomber sur un agent qui même un agent
cuche du voyage
moi je dirais je marche de guanyin le
sexe enfin je vois pas le sexe et pour
cause son père ne soit pas le nom mais
je vois personne et jamais je traverse
je traverse donc même si une bonne heure
se présentait pas disponible et je crois
que je laissais zimbler ça y est oui
mais justement racontez moi te dire que
max et peut-être l'homme la mort la
femme la femme de ma vie j'avais cia
backs ouzou et c'est elle a pris
absolument l'ensemble voyez je veux dire
non même si apparemment oui
c'est donc à partir de là il va dire que
je suis un menteur
regardez temps en temps ou un peu
partout alors c'est vrai que je suis
d'abord j'ai très hâte et moi qui suis
moche je suis très attiré par la beauté
non c'est pareil je veux pas
personnellement moi personnellement je
me rase de dos pour pas me voir mais
c'est vrai que j'aime bien ce qui est
bon par exemple j'aime bien la nuit
n'ont pas elles non j'aime bien je veux
dire j'aime bien ce qui est bon pour moi
ce qui peut être moche pour d'autres se
trouvent que la séduction c'est plein de
choses quoi c'est une somme c'est comme
l'intelligence qui fait pas vous voyez
une somme de choses et a apporté un
petit trait pillay a marqué séduction
oui donc faut quand même une somme de
choses
howie faut quand même plusieurs étapes à
ce que j'imaginais un regard de
merveilleux et puis on ouvre la bouche
on dit c'est pas possible d'offrir une
sorte d'enfant pas du tout aux moi même
j'aime beaucoup de mal à perdre bien je
suis allée rue des morillons ils l'ont
pas retrouvé
mais vous savez vous parlez de japon
vous savez une grande fête il n'empêche
on en parlera tout d'abord présenté ces
essais jeunes filles patrouille à karine
les puits
darina c'est pas vous c'est pas facile
c'est d'alcina dak lak chine à dakar
dac china d'acino jack bonne j'aurais pu
nous dire ah non le régime du prénom
allons-y
patricia patricia c'est la première elle
est le fruit d'un doux mélange d'origine
russe égyptiennes et américaines sa
passion ce sont les animaux
particulièrement les chevaux c'est une
femme qui sait mettre le pied à l'étrier
et qui sait en fourche et le bon cheval
[Musique]
la seconde c'est karine c'est karine
alvia du nord mais pas du même nord
vient de ville le point commun quand
même avec gérard hernandez c'est que son
père est allemand et sa mère normande
oui absolument elle cartonne beaucoup
lorsqu'elle tient au revolver c'est une
de ses passions tireur revolver les
salles de tir j'ai dit dans mon revolver
oui oui et elle fait aussi un sport de
combat qui s'appelle le pen chaque à
l'open chapeau 16 faveur des nouilles
des relances des nouilles il faut
rattraper le sol un peu parce que j'ai
je restais pas de bagnole je suis nue
grosse nature de deux manières
d'actionner assez bien la troisième
comme son prénom lundi qu'elle est
d'origine française
elle a beaucoup d'ennemis sérieuses et
12 à la fois elle a beaucoup beaucoup de
mérite d'être venu aujourd'hui parce que
l anacs vip d'être équipé mais enfin au
rendez-vous quand avec gérard mendes ou
le seul ou pas même si on a la grève
mais les portes un taxi là ça vient d'où
dax final je crois c
indien ses vrais amis le dira peut-être
[Musique]
bien vous savez vous pouvez participer
également cette émission vous qui nous
regardent et en choisissant la jeune
femme qui aura le mieux séduire
hernandez en fin d'émission il suffit
pour ça j'ai foncé sur mobilité elle
vous tapez 36,15 que les faire traduire
le vae
si vous n'avez pas de mitel foncé la
poste afin de dire je vais retrouver
bougeant le guichetier de la poste
et puis vous nous donnez prénom de celle
qui d'après bourg a été la plus basse et
de la thiérache père c'était ce que je
sais faire la séduction
je n'ai pas entendu un mot de ce que
vous avez dit oui j'ai vu plein de
choses
voilà c'est ça la séduction avez vous
suffit de suivre celle alaoui on
comprendre même si vanessa crone motifs
on continue allez je vais présenter
maintenant le jury du jeu de la
sélection il y aura le groupe reporter
il voit pas le 2 way son très bien sûr
jeff joseph une loi pour lui tout seul
patrick barreaux et effi libre ou une
voix pour 2 michel
jin yu notre héroïne préférée et puis le
chef que je vous présenterai tout à
l'heure et morita dériot tiens on la
mettra dans le jury la petite dame à
droite la wii wheel elle votera tout à
l'heure pourquoi pas toute extrapolation
comme ça grâce à lui j'ai appris à
compter en anglais one two three
cette idée sachant sans faire d'éclat et
c'est pour bientôt on entendra tout à
l'heure en fait mandat chaque candidate
comme ça je me prends la tête me tourne
savoir ce qu'ils pensent de gérard
hernandez ont commencé par patricia si
vous avez un petit micro patricia oui on
voudrait entendre voilà vos propos eh
bien je trouve que gérard a le charme le
charme latin et un regard très très
chaleureux voilà voilà un regard qui
brille c'est police que la fesse et
policé mais là c'est mignon c'est mignon
un regard chaleureux je n'ai pas ça
brille ça change tellement je vais les
garder un peu de mains green attention
bien moi je le trouve bien qu'il se
trouve pas très beau moi je trouve très
séducteur fait ce qu il un petit père un
art sharif dire oui bon bah oui mais on
n'aime pas ressembler à quelqu'un
monseigneur bbc que je préfère
ressembler à omar sharif kaka omar
sharif un peu terne peter tut hernandez
quoi un petit air je ressens un grand
show man et dessine à moi je trouve
qu'il est naturel qu'il a quelque chose
d'attirant lui j'ai pas de colorants non
gelabale collet qui les lui l'a tout
simplement
c'est intéressant quoi c'est bien
justement les choix que vous avez
beaucoup mais mais dès que tu n'as rien
à dire
il est naturel il est lui c'est vrai
vous êtes autant pitre dans la vie comme
ça c'est un peu mais quand on peut bien
sûr c'est une carapace mais je m'en sers
tout le temps oui c'est à dire des cons
et là vous savez mon public
naulleau a fait semblant quand j étais
pas dans ce métier non non non j'ai
toujours fait ça parce que c'est une
façon détournée l'angoissé comment
autrement sinon ouais c'est beau enfin
preuve est un prophète c'est plutôt sont
pas du tout c'est drôle quand même temps
oui non même avec des gens non j'essaie
je crois qu'il faut pas se prendre au
sérieux quoi c'est très important
vous êtes potentiellement gay pas du
tout ah non pas du tout compris non je
suis paquet du tout je suis très très
angoissée très c'est pour ça que je
déconne tout le temps parce que sans ça
on se tire une balle dans le jeu penche
déjà dire il faut ils font du célé l'oms
et bien des moments sur ce choix
non non c'est soit on est tous ensemble
c'est ce que je disais je suis toujours
tous aujourd'hui sauf à la télé selon
mme anne marie blanc je suis très sombre
la journée regardez le mot qu est-ce qui
va pas mais rien ne va pas ce que ça va
tout ça va finir je dirais ça peut pas
aller on ne peut pas être optimiste dans
la vie c'est pas possible
donc il faut être un joyeux pessimiste
être lucide et se bagarrer contre toutes
ces angoisses avec deux de la joie en
plus il dit vrai mais c'est le procédé d
un jour mais ce livret jeu l'école en
général un petit fond de vrai voilà moi
je reste avec amanda lear on va finir
tout ça en beauté en écoutant la
première candidate c'est patricia qui a
deux minutes pour séduire gérer un an
deiz sur une peau y arriver je pense que
c'est facile d'aller déjà bien démarré
allez-y
je vous écoute mon petit bonjour merci
[Musique]
j'adore la politesse groupe
mais jean pauly un bonjour monsieur
alors que oui
est-ce que c'est qu'on voit pas la chose
d'équivalent pour pour faire le plein de
ma voiture parce que le pompiste et
charmant les utopistes non pas pour le
pompiste pour l'accueil non talibans la
petite bombe à côté on se téléphone et
on se fait comme h michel
connaissez-vous déjà mangé oui mais j'ai
déjà vous aimez les animaux bâton us
j'ai la passion et une passe de relever
exactement tout alors de regarder les
animaux et je me disais que finalement
c'est vrai que c'est mieux de les
laisser en liberté et de départ c'est
votre enfant notre candidat mais dites
moi quelque chose par une passion non
non non je suis pas seul paramètre
passion vous savez j'aime les gens qui
sont passionnés jamais vous allez papa
sur l'autre médecine
oui oui comme j'ai tellement de passion
je peux pas dire que je suis passionné
son sérieux et vous avez les cheveux
oui j'ai je leur ai d'ailleurs beaucoup
à manger non non j'allais aux courses gp
me j'allais à longchamp
j'adorais ça non
il faut pas justement parce que voilà
j'ai écrit un petit scénario est
effectivement vous êtes exactement
non non non non non pas du tout
et justement voilà je vais vous parlez
pas si l'histoire d'un homme qui
rencontre phare mai
très bonne idée très bon et c'est qu'ils
savent amour à bombay et ces spams et à
signer par les chevaux
est elle partie à cheval et elle
l'emmène et elle fait découvrir
justement ce monde des chevaux
oui est ce que ça vous intéresse
oui c'est vrai c'est formidable mais
vous montez à chaleur il n'y a pas de
problème je vous apprends un montage
vous m'apprenez à monter à cheval avant
d'aller à tout va bien non mais
l'appareil est ce que la demande
d'ailleurs monte à cheval a pas du tout
non il n'ya pas de micro non plus bon
ben master on va écouter la deuxième
candidate ccam craignent qu'à deux
minutes pour pour se dire également
gérard hernandez elle a l'air intimidée
pourquoi ces petites misères fois les
directs thierry tweet alors vous allez
m'apprendra montage
après ce n'est plus la même excusez moi
j'avais une énorme et on a su c'était
bon et je faisais moi alors la foule
mais vrai je peux vous poser une
question absolument
enfin distributeur de surgelés commencé
fin trop léger plus alors vraiment
j'aime jouer c'est le meilleur alors
attendez voilà allégorique
si vous saviez
un habit une femme à bia bi 1
vous imagineriez comment habiller une
femme en bien c'est récolte me poser
cette question parce que je m'intéresse
pas tellement aux vêtements non non je
dis ça je dois je dire c'est pas une
chose qui me qui m'interpelle interprète
le vêtement si je suis pas du tout alors
on l'a déshabillé non plus joli ça se
fait quoi comme visait ça c'est des
choses qui se font mais c'est pas but
dans la désunion et alors quel
compliment
par quel compliment une vrille et vous
qu'une femme vous fasse très écouté je
vous faire la liste si on a pas mal que
voilà j'aimerais que vous me disiez que
je suis très très beau et en revanche je
suis très intelligent et qu'est-ce que
je suis jeune aventurier qu est ce une
menteuse parce que finalement il faut
être vous savez partie faut être lucide
dans la vie faut être lucide faut de
plus il faut se connaître
enfin je ne plaît pas mais absolument
vous ne les aimez vous avez deux
malheureuses avec moi je suis un
aventurier ou ça m'arrive des footballs
vanover et puis le lendemain je me
levais à 9h10
voyez jamais pareil
nous sommes un groupe à je sais bien que
je sais bien que cette attirance que
vous avez vers moi mais cela malheureux
vous seriez malheureuse parce que parce
que parce que je suis mais les problèmes
et d'art china troisième candidate deux
minutes également avec ça un an deiz
allez-y vous voulez quoi un peu d'eau
inquiète
pardon ça va très bien et je me régale
et en plus au monde
comporte des montagnes merveilleuse il y
en a pour moi j'ai pas fini non mais
j'aime beaucoup le repas complet vas-y
d'arsenal à votre sens ça revient de
retard a quant à elle
[Musique]
je vais être pété encore j'ai passé mon
texte
c'est bon bien tu as écouté je tiens à
vous remercier d'abord parce que vous
êtes que vous êtes grippe et oui faut
prendre un peu plus sa cavale unique et
votre mac les chaussures mais je suis
venu comme ça j'avais envie de vous
rencontrer
c'est vrai vous n'aviez qu'à me
téléphoner on serait mieux ailleurs ou
non mais c'est très sympa de vote pas
parce que c'est vrai que non mais c'est
ça va ça va mais pour les autres c'est
un peu difficile mais j'avais vraiment
envie de vous rencontrer suis quelqu'un
de se dire de d'intéressant ah bon oui
me rends pas bien compte ça voyez où
attention vous avez fait tomber un petit
grain de riz là vous d'accord oui oui
parler encore de moi ça me fait plaisir
bon nom elles répondent par les deux
mois vous avez vu ma dernière pièce ou
non je suis désolé
pardon monsieur vous avez vu merci s'il
vous plaît essayez encore de la langue
je vous invite dans des films c'est vrai
mais vous m'avez vu au cinéma
oh oui ah oui j'y vais souvent j'y vais
très souvent tous mes parents sont en ce
moment c'est vous dire le cinéma on en
fait pas beaucoup hélas non hélas tu dis
ça parce que j'adore le cinéma c'est
formidable cinéma alors le cinéma
bon bah rad soc est trop sûr ils ont un
portable ou un si beau si c'est bon hein
c'est très bon voyez ce qui est
formidable c'est ces anti racistes ce
qu'on fait là manger de la cuisine
d'ailleurs c'est un peu aimer les autres
ces beautés à toi où ils veulent aller
jouer bien sûr comme le français
trégueux l'art c'est très bien
finalement si on connaissait une
français mais bien la cuisine arabe
il aime à mieux vous voyez un problème
c'est complètement stupide ce que les
divas mais je me rends compte à compte
c'est grave la ccc du liban
bien je vais demander à gérard hernandez
de venir me rejoindre ici on était
d'amanda lear ses volants pour gérard
wyss qu'elle vient de me dire
et puis je vais demander toute
juridiction le manifester plus pour
leurs votes alors exceptionnellement
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de militaires
parce que ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
peut-être parce qu'il n'ya pas de
répondant dans les téléphones puisqu'on
est un jour férié donc on va changer un
tout petit peu la formule juste pour
rire
là ça va être le jury du jeu de la
séduction qui va voter après avoir la
chanson pour le suspense et après je
demanderai à certaines personnes du
public qui ne voudront bien de voter et
d'être les porte pas la parole en fait
d'eux des téléspectateurs qui d'habitude
vous êtes d'accord ou pas il faut partir
qu'il est un petit micro et puis vous
vous interviendrez alors je demande
d'abord à au groupe reporter de nous
dire ce qui peut tout nous dire c'est
difficile parce que sans doute et 3
séduisante et beaucoup de charme mais je
crois que la dernière personne c'est
patricia h - c'est ça ouais c'est pour
elle ok patricia way la première jeune
fille laide à la dernière non non non la
dernière cet art chinois china mais
pourquoi vous êtes vous êtes concerné
tous les deux c'est bon oui tout à fait
ok et pourquoi il ya une petite
explication parce qu'elle est simple
pour fait elle sait parler gérard en
fait elle n'est pas du tout d'accord
bien il a pu en placer une
oui ok merci jeff joseph cedar qui na
waie j'aime bien le nom alors donné
j'aime bien quoi à l'avenir
j'aime bien le nom parce qu'elle est
très charmante je trouve qu'il est très
charmant y est pourquoi pas il voit pour
les deux philippe roux et patrick
barreaux alors nous ce sera là la
première attia wi lan slave
pourquoi la baisse on aime bien les
brunes d'accord oui mais c'est bien mame
saye aussi bien michel guiniot moi aussi
ce serait la première pourquoi parce
qu'elle doit avoir
très chaud avec ce chapeau la pauvre et
que bon c'est amélie monica dériot que
je n'ai pas présenté qui est un grand
talent de comédien sur la place de paris
vers une tresse cas notamment avec une
grande comédienne très très grande
comédienne je veux que le public le sage
à droite on me dit à patricia karine
audard chine à l'e3 je vais vous dire
pourquoi je trouvais très très difficile
de séduire me suis en deuil je crois
qu'il faudrait plusieurs émissions
originales vainqueur donc toutes les
tranches et aime beaucoup la cuisine
chinoise elle enfreint la règle elle
fait nouveau et à one drop le mantra
difficile très dense est excellent et
son charmant garçon charmant
bon d'accord donc trois voies patricia
travois d'art chine a une voix karine
puisque j'en ai mis une à chacune de la
part de minutes à l'est gérard
hernandez voix comptent double on voit
qu'on me doubler moi je voulais
absolument récompensé d'un championnat
qui malgré sa maladie est venue tout de
même mais il ya eu un discours parce que
je bavarde parce que je suis d'une
grande timidité c'est pour ça alors
j'étais un peu gêné avait le trac alors
je parlais pour des conneries on dit
qu'il ya des conneries oui oui la mairie
mais parce que j'ai je voyais une sorte
de petite tension alors j'ai dit des
bêtises mais en heineken qui m'a coupé
la parole il faut quand même le faire
cesser
la première qui m'a raconté à sénart et
la télé très maligne moi je veux dire
c'est très malade attaqué un comédien
usage à sénart pour et et finalement
comme je suis plus de quoi faut dire la
vérité est que le travail compte n'est
ce pas alors je me dis si ce film se
fait aux autres pas pour elle je vais
pas le faire alors je vais dire je vais
dire la première mais que pour que par
intérêt je suis navré mais c'est un
jouet c'est pas très sympa pour toutes
ces raisons la wii pour des raisons
professionnelles
c'est peut-être finalement c'est
peut-être le kubrick de demain donc pour
l'instant patricia à cinq voix car il
une voie dans china à trois voix j'avais
dit que cinq personnes du plus gros prêt
vous représenterez faute de temps on
peut pas le faire je vais quand même
demandé une personne du public qui est
tous là haut puisqu'il ya déjà le micro
quais près de dire si d'abord il est
d'accord avec avec la gagnante qui est
patricia normalement c'est ce que vous
avancez grille est là pour la troisième
la troisième c'est en chine à qingdao
est pourquoi parce que à l'échelon de
caractère et ben voilà donc ça peut être
la représentation du public qui nous
regardent darche n'a une fois de plus
mais ça fait quand même quatre voix
contre patricia qui en a qui en a cinq
bravo patricia à l'etrat gagnant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]